self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anyone else does
that's really interesting to me I think
it's believing in the 85 year old
version of you
who's exactly who you want to be and
then
ruthlessly
looking at the discrepancy between the
the pittance of a human that you are now
compared to that man or that woman and
then step by step breaking down the many
differences and starting on the first
one and pulling the thread
I love the idea that
in a true true self-love a lot of the
time is wrapped in acceptance
and a degree of belonging I reject this
entirely I just wanna I just want to
throw it out there that doesn't surprise
me
the idea
that self-love is holding yourself to a
higher standard than anyone else does
you believing in you
more
than anybody else does
is such a first principle's way of
looking at self-love Okay so
I'm supposed to love myself I'm supposed
to support myself and be my biggest fan
but I don't have the most belief in me
so
I'm supposed to have self-love but I cap
my own potential
I have so many thoughts
so right off the bat even the concept of
fan was something that I I if I was if I
was talking to 2013 2012 Alex I would
have rejected that notion not like the
the concept of even being a fan of
myself was so foreign to me it wouldn't
been real to me and so I'll tell you
with that Alex internalized which was
that I didn't need to deserve success
but I could still have it if I did the
things that created success and so it
felt like a cheat code where I was like
I can actually be a shitty person and
horrible and suck at everything but if I
still work out and I still eat this way
I can still look this way even though I
don't deserve it and that was like the
first it actually felt like I was like
it for anybody who hates themselves you
can hear me
um that was like my first big shade my
first Solace my first foothold that I
started getting on success was that I
didn't need to deserve it I could still
have it anyways and that was like very
empowering for me
the other thing that you said about
acceptance
so
there's this big movement around
self-acceptance and I want to say that I
wholeheartedly reject it
I
you accept outcomes and you accept
circumstances you accept the fact that
you were dealt whatever hand you were
dealt you accept that you're five eight
you accept that you're black you accept
that you're a woman that's accepting
you're trying to rebel against that is
you trying to fight the universe and the
universe is going to win every time
but in terms of you framing acceptance
as saying that
I am comfortable with who I am and I
cannot be better and I must be satisfied
with that
is the biggest embodiment
a failure that I can imagine is that
it's almost it's almost it's almost
egotistical
to say that
there's a difference between saying I am
good enough and I am good
so you could say I am good enough for my
current state based on the work that
I've put into it but I could be better
and so like
you can accept that the work that you
have done has created the outcome that
you've created but you do not need to
accept that the outcome that you've
created is the end-all be-all and the
last outcome that you need to need to
have and so for me like
the only version of acceptance that I
have is that I accept
that the version of myself that I want
to be is is so far from who I am that I
have this massive discrepancy that I
have to overcome and then just breaking
that down one step at a time and
thinking I don't
I don't deserve to be that man
but I can still do the things
that can create it and it also means
that I have to go through the
circumstances that that would create
that man which means that if I have
unbelievable Big Dreams and big goals
then I have to go through hard times
it's like hate the hard times are a
requisite for success and so if you're
going through hard times right now it
means that you're on the path to success
and it's not that you're on the wrong
path it's the feeling of being on the
right path and one of the things that I
talk with with the CEOs in our portfolio
company and I'm I'm going to bring it
back
one of our companies
they were struggling with growth big
company and he was like I honestly the
issue that I have right now is like I I
don't know how many locations I can open
every month he's like based on the cash
flow that's coming in and out and I was
like this is kind of like the Morpheus
free frame and I was like I need you to
freeze this moment I was like the
feeling that you have right now is that
you are missing a finance function is
that they didn't have a good Finance
leader and you're like why is this
relative to what we're talking about
I'll bring it back which is that
if it's the first time you're going
through it you can't recognize the
science because you don't have anything
to compare it to and so hopefully
listening to this podcast and listening
to other people not just you know not me
and Chris but like other people who are
even even more successful whatever
they can at least tell you what it
tastes like they can tell you what the
room looks like they can tell you what
the temperature feels like they can tell
you what it feels like in their body so
that when you are going through it you
can say okay I haven't been here before
but this sounds like Albuquerque this
sounds like a missing finance and that's
why having like and if you're in the
early on stages and and you're going
through the like you're going You're
consuming the free content is less stuff
it's like use this because the most
valuable thing you can get is the
context of what the experience feels
like when you're going through it so
someone can describe to you their
experience so that you can relate it to
your present and be like okay I'm on the
right path yeah it's the feeling of
loneliness and uncertainty hang on what
if this what if this is a sign that I'm
not supposed to be here what if this is
a sign that I'm doing it wrong right and
relinquishing that the
if there was a big meta indicator that
you're doing the right thing doing what
everyone isn't doing is already probably
the biggest the single biggest indicator
that you're doing the right thing like
it's it's the if if I could wish nothing
else on my child whenever I choose to
have them in the future is that they
have high agency which is that they are
they make decisions independent from the
opinions of other people and when we
hear words like authentic and original
and things like that it's because the
person starts at square one and says
well what do I want and then they start
building from there I had a conversation
with one of my one of my teammates
um who runs our my LinkedIn
and he said you know Alex it's easy for
you
it's always always a really great start
great way to trigger
really good please
tell me more what do you
go on he said it's it's easy for you
Alex to create this personal brand he's
like you have so many interesting things
about you he's like you dress a certain
way you act a certain way and he said
it's different than everyone else does
right
and I said
I don't think that's true I think that
everyone has a personal brand that is
unique and different but everyone
doesn't look that way because they
conform to whatever what they think
everyone else wants them to look like
and so the fact that they are boring and
they resent the fact that they're boring
is because they are living out
reflections of what what they think
everyone else wants them to do and so
all you have to do is start at Square
zero and be like what do I want because
I realized after I got out of gym launch
that I mean I addressed a certain way
for too much because I was the head of
an entire community of gyms and it made
sense for me to dress that way because I
needed to
I needed to look that part right but
when I was at Ground Zero and I was like
okay what do I want and I thought about
it for a long time and I was like well
what would 85 year old me wear I was
like 85 year old me would wear probably
the most functional thing he could wear
because he doesn't care what his shoes
look like he doesn't care what his shirt
looks like he just wants to be
comfortable and so I just started trying
all the things that I could possibly
imagine for shoes shorts hats whatever
to find the thing that I was like you
know what
this is the most comfortable and this
allows me to do the most things in the
most rooms without changing and so
people then are like man that's so
unique but it was actually just saying
if I were to or if everyone was gone
from existence what would I do what
would my work be right how would I dress
who would I date that's a real one who
would I date if no one else told me what
they thought about it maybe someone
different than you're dating right now
and if the person that you would want to
date isn't the person you're dating
right now and the person that you'd want
to date would never date you
then maybe rather than dating these
mediocre mollies or mediocre mats
you take the period of time you go on
the untrodden path you have people
reject you and say oh you're not coming
out tonight you're going to the gym
again right oh I can't eat with us right
she's on it she's on a diet again how
long I'm gonna stick with this one right
because the thing is is that the stick
to it and muscle itself is something
that you work on because if you start a
diet and you failed and you started
working out and you failed if you just
make it longer every time before you
fail you're still making progress and
you're still doing something that
everyone else isn't doing yeah and that
is the biggest meta indicator that you
possibly can is if because
everyone sucks like so many people are
mediocre like half of the United States
is in debt they don't even have a DOT
like they their their negative net worth
and so like just saying different than
that like the bar isn't High we'll get
back to talking to Alex in one minute
but first I need to tell you about
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't it's a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it's how I've
started my morning every single day for
over three years you do not need to have
coffee first thing in the morning
because you're adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't even active but
your adrenal system is and salt acts on
your adrenal system element contains a
signed backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium that
helps to regulate appetite curb cravings
and improve your brain function but best
of all tastes phenomenal this orange
salt is unbelievable in a cold glass of
water first thing in the morning and
they have a no BS no questions asked
refund policy if you don't like it for
any reason they'll give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom
oh hey thanks for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip then press here for
the full three hour podcast with Alex
go on
press it
foreign